believe it or not a clock on your head
beats at a different rate than a clock
on your foot we can now measure this and
it has practical importance as well
first of all I'm Stine said that time is
a river so gigantic river we're all
swept up in the river of time and it can
speed up and it slows down for example
on the moon did you know that time beats
faster on the moon than it does on the
earth and we can measure this on Jupiter
time beats slower on Jupiter than it
does on the earth so time beats at
different rates
when an object moves very fast time
slows down inside that rocket that is
moving very fast if that rocket is then
placed on the moon time beats faster so
we have two competing effects this has a
direct implication with regards to your
cell phone your cell phone has GPS which
allows you to locate objects on the
planet Earth by focusing in on
satellites orbiting the planet earth
satellites travel at 18,000 miles per
hour if they're in low-earth orbit
therefore time slows down for those
low-lying satellites but if satellites
go farther and farther away gravity gets
less and less and less so time speeds up
so we're not a space we have two
competing effects fast satellites slow
down in time very far away satellites
slow speed up in time and in fact at one
radius you can calculate time beats
exactly the same rate as it does in the
planet Earth so what does it mean your
GPS system would totally fail without
Einstein's theory of special and general
relativity this also means that the top
of your head because it is farther from
the center of the earth beats at a
faster rate time beats at a faster rate
than your feet so you can actually show
that even within your own body now our
instruments are so accurate that you
could show within your own body the fact
that time beats at different rates
within your own body
you